جد الفتاه وهو السيد اشرف حلواني الذي
ينضم الينا الان هاتفيا سيد اشرف مرحبا بك
معي على شاشه العربيه تتابع تغطيه العربيه
لهذه
المحاولات محاولات انقاذ الفتاه التي
يعني حفيدتكم التي يعني لا زالت تحت
الانقاض كيف تتابعونها ايضا باي عين
ونحاول فقط معك ان نفهم يعني الشعور شعور
الجد في هذه اللحظات
جزاكم الله كل خير واتابعها وانا باعصاب
بعد انهارت الاعصاب بشكل كامل اعيدت لنا
الحياه والان نستنى اعاده الحياه للحظه
الاخيره للحصيده الاخيره بعدما توفيت
ابنته وفخري وحفيده الصغرى الحمد لله
الاثنتين بحاله جيده وانا اشكر
قناتكم واشكر فرقه الانقاذ الاجر بجانيه
التي تقوم فيها واشكر الشعب التركي الذي
هو
في هذا العمل الذي يقومون فيه الذي لا
يقدر بثمن لا نطلب من الله ان يجزيهم عننا
كل الخير من قناتكم الكريمه التي
لها كل الشكر وكل الشكر الجزيل في متابعتي
بهذه الاحداث
الحساس